avoue t il ya trois modes d'inscription
soit donc la première démarche en se
rendant à la mairie de son domicile soit
en ligne sur internet
ou alors attention par correspondance
trois conditions de base est majeur
être de nationalité française et jouir
de ses droits civiques ça c'est
important
la carte d'identité en cours de validité
ou périmés depuis moins d'un an
un passeport en cours de validité ou
périmés depuis moins d'un an
un justificatif de domicile moins de
trois mois c'est suffisant pour
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
jusqu'au 31 décembre anticiper la
demande anticipé la demande on a eu des
cas limites on a vu des fois des
demandes qui arrivé le 31 décembre à
23h50
parce que la dernière heure c'est 23h59
oui c'est arrivé à voter